i'm jason chief it's in for laura ingram
and this is a special edition of the
ingram angle
when you think about a shameless swamp
filled dc it usually refers to the
grifton git gridlock that populate the
halls of congress and lobbying shops
but now d.c mayor muriel bowser is
getting in on the action and begging the
national guard for help dealing with the
influx of illegals coming into the city
which seems pretty hypocritical coming
from someone who declared this back when
trump was being inaugurated i can't say
it anymore clearly of what it means to
for
for washington d.c to be a sanctuary
city and to ensure that people who live
here
feel free to call on their government
for help
and call on the government for help she
did red state governors like abbott in
texas and ducey and arizona have been
sending illegals to our nation's capital
by bus for the last few months
some even arrived as recently as this
morning this is a very small little tiny
portion we're talking about 4 000 people
out of millions who have crossed our
borders
and now that bowser is seeing what
border states have been dealing with
since biden and harris came into office
it's not in my backyard
the department of defense of course is
jumping all over this saying quote the
secretary takes this request for
assistance very
seriously the question now becomes if
it's so easy for bowser to call in the
national guard and get legitimate
immediate response from the department
of defense why aren't other states doing
exactly the same thing
this was the gist of a truly remarkable
back and forth at the white house
yesterday that speaks to the greater
issue here watch this
is the president going to approve that
request for the national guard we have
been in regular touch with mayor bowser
and her team
and i said this before i said this last
week about republicans using migrants
as a political tool
and that is shameful and that is just
wrong so the white house's preference
would be for small towns in texas and
arizona to have to take care of these
migrants rather than a large
metropolitan that's not what i said
washington that is not what i said
i said that there is
yeah they are they're sending migrants
to big cities on purpose using them as a
political point they don't go to big
cities where should they go
i just laid it out there's a problem
they come to a big city and now but this
mayor says the national guard that's
because that's because republicans are
using they're using migrants
who are coming here for who knows
because they are they're they're dealing
with humanitarian issues back in their
country they're coming here for a better
life and they are being used
peter they're being used by republican
governors that is what's happening let's
just make the president
want to say this is causing a lot of
burdens on small cities big cities maybe
i should just close the border what i'm
saying is what republicans are doing is
wrong and there is a process in place
and we should follow the process
wow
joining me now is new york congressman
and gubernatorial candidate lee zeldin
and texas congressman chip roy
uh thank you i i got had the pleasure of
serving uh with you uh let's go to
congressman roy first uh that the
hypocrisy here is just dripping with
hypocrisy what's your reaction to what
the white house is saying
oh my gosh i mean i could sit here for
all night long it's great to be on with
my friend lee zeldin and you know great
candidate for governor in new york and
i'm proud to serve with him let me just
say something i mean listening to her
talk about that republicans are using
these migrants it's offensive it is
democrats are using these migrants but
more importantly it's cartels who are
using these migrants because while the
news is focused and fixated on mayor
bowser complaining about 4 000 migrants
coming to dc because governor abbott
said hey we're going to put some bus
loads and take them to d.c when we get 4
000 a day there were 73 human beings
found in a stash house in washington dc
in a stash house where they get put into
the human trafficking trade because
we're allowing cartels to move these
human beings for profit in the false
name of compassion while my democrat
colleagues pat themselves on the back
and meanwhile these people are put into
this ridiculous trade for profit for
cartels i can't even put it into words
and for the to listen to the white house
press secretary say we're using them
they are the ones using them let me tell
you there are people in south texas who
are sick of it that's why we saw maura
flores do well that's why we're seeing a
big change in the politics in south
texas and uh you know it's just a shame
that my democratic colleagues want to
use them for politics yeah no it is i
it's just unbelievable they would come
to that conclusion congressman zelda and
the federal government has been
reportedly sending secret overnight
flights to new york for months planes
filled with illegals fbn's edward
lawrence confronted the white house
about it today watch this
what's the difference between texas
busing migrants to d.c and the federal
government flying migrants to say new
york in the middle of the night in other
cities it's very different because we're
not doing it as a as using migrants as a
political part
congressman zeldin what's your response
to that
well first off we have to shut down that
travel agency that's flying people into
new york and the fact that they are
flying people into new york in the dead
of night and there's that lack of
transparency really shows you a lot
about what they're trying to accomplish
here behind the scenes
if this was something that they were
proud of then they would be talking
about these flights and there would be
data of how many flights are coming
there'd be a heads up that they're
coming
they would be able to stand by that
travel agency as far as what's going on
at the border that really ultimately is
the way that this whole issue gets
resolved it's finishing construction of
the border walls ending catch and
release it's enforcing the remaining
mexico policy and supporting our customs
and border patrol agents on top of
shutting down that travel agency that is
sending people into new york in the
middle of the
night yeah congressman rory shouldn't
that shouldn't barrio bowser shouldn't
she be calling like ice or maybe the
border patrol isn't that the way to deal
with this
yeah you would think but the fact of the
matter is that my democratic colleagues
in particularly the bide administration
and in particular secretary marcus who
lied to me and every member of the house
judiciary committee in all of america
when he said that they have operational
control of the border which is a blatant
lie
we could solve this problem with policy
changes tomorrow right i went to eagle
pass texas three weeks ago i went to a
processing facility let me explain to
america they're bringing people into a
processing facility they're then
processing them and releasing them into
the united states under notice to appear
or parole they're not even going through
asylum claim processing the only barrier
to a complete flood is the use of title
42 and the bite administration wants to
get rid of that that being the title 42
policies under covet it's absurd it's a
complete violation of our laws and
frankly secretary america should be
impeached for it and hopefully we can
address that next year congressman
zeldin donald trump was called zetaphobe
it was xenophobic by by putting up the
border wall but biden is now saying
despite a pledge not to put another foot
of wall in place that he's going to
start filling in the wall in yuma why do
we think he's doing that
um and
what's the what's at play here
the right call the will of the people on
the merit it would be to finish
construction of the border wall
and to see the the amount of money that
the federal government was spending to
not build this wall and then you want to
talk about utilizing this issue with
regards to political pawns it was this
administration that we have right now
that was going after our own customs and
border patrol and accusing them of
whipping people coming across and then
the media running with it
and you know we're seeing the stories
now as you you start talking about the
dc mayor in new york city you had the
mayor talking about how the shelters
were being overrun
and you think that you have it bad
think about being the governor right now
of texas or being the governor of
arizona they have it a thousand times
worse what we all should be doing is at
every level working together but this
push towards sanctuary state and
sanctuary city policies and this blame
game and the spin with an election
coming up is resulting on in more people
being incentivized and rewarded to come
across it's going to get worse until we
confront this yeah no clearly this is
human trafficking it's drug trafficking
but thank goodness we got vice president
kamala harris on top of it congressman
zeldin congressman wright thanks for
joining us tonight hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else